c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir la visite de philippe de
belgique en république démocratique du
congo le roi des belges accompagnés du
premier ministre et des deux ministres
est de deux ministres et dans le pays
pour six jours une visite pour resserrer
les liens entre les deux pays après des
années de tensions quelles sont les
attentes des congolais les réactions
dans ce journal les militaires au
pouvoir au mali ont fixé la transition à
21 mois le colonel à ses minorités a
signé un décret pour un retour du
pouvoir aux civils en mars 2024 une
décision qui a pour but de rassurer la
cedeao qui a imposé de lourdes stance
sanctions sur le pays
la polémique au sénégal après le rejet
de la liste de la coalition d'opposition
et oui askan wi notre invité ce soir et
le ministre des pêches et de l'économie
maritime
alioune d'oeil également tête de liste
bono boc yaakaar dans le département de
dakar pour les législatives de juillet
il répondra entre autres aux accusations
de l'opposition entretien dans un
instant
c'est une visite historique qui a entamé
à philippe de belgique en république
démocratique du congo
le roi des belges est arrivé dans le
pays ce mardi pour six jours accompagné
de la reine mathilde du premier ministre
et de deux ministres objectif principal
resserrer les liens entre les deux pays
après des années de tension notamment
sont l'ancien président joseph kabila à
qu'attendent les congolais de cette
visite notre correspondant clément
bonnerot est allé à leur rencontre
écoutez pour de nombreux congolais la
visite du roi philippe de belgique doit
d'abord être l'occasion d'aborder le
passé colonial il y a deux ans le roi
avait exprimé ses profonds regrets pour
les blessures causées par la
colonisation mais désormais certains
attendent plus écoutés je voudrais
seulement dire que au cas où il venait
qui puisse nous présenter ses excuses
par rapport à ceux qui nous ont fait 6
lire dans les passes et la première
chose c'est de demander pardon ça
devenait départ tenté de convoler pour
les crimes que
la belgique a commis au congo nous à
cette ville de fous rires nous faut
lutter les ancêtres depuis quelques
années les questions mémorielles sont au
coeur du débat politique en belgique et
bruxelles a d'ailleurs lancé plusieurs
chantiers dans ce domaine là dans de
l'ancien premier ministre patrice
lumumba assassiné en 1961 sera ainsi
rendu au congo dont les prochaines
semaines et la belgique a aussi promis
de restituer les objets d'art volés
pendant la période coloniale jusqu'à
maintenant
nos objets d'art en grande partie s'est
trouvé en belgique et surtout que nous
venons déconstruire
les grands bâtiments des gros bâtiment
pour mieux conserver cette visite
intervient aussi dans un contexte de
regain de violences dans l'est du pays
avec notamment les attaques du m23 un
groupe que kinshasa accuse d'être
soutenus par le rwanda certains
congolais demande à bruxelles de
s'impliquer davantage dans ce dossier
les combos ne peut pas être abandonnée
aux nouveaux où il est arrivé nous avons
besoin que le roi
exporter la voie du congo comme ça s'est
fait en son temps donc c'est la belgique
peut aujourd'hui décidé de travailler à
côté de convoler pour que le congo est
trop frappé après kinshasa le roi et la
reine ont prévu de se rendre à
lubumbashi dans le sud du pays puis à
bukavu dans l'est
mars 2024 c'est la date que se sont
fixés les autorités militaires au mali
pour rendre le pouvoir aux civils encore
21 mois aux manettes un délai qui a pour
objectif de rassurer la cedeao qui avait
imposé de lourdes sanctions à bamako
début janvier florent road où
elle dirige le pays depuis son coup
d'état de l'été 2020 sous pression de
ses partenaires ouest africain la junte
militaire malienne s'est engagé à rendre
le pouvoir aux civils dans moins de deux
ans date butoir de cette transition le
mois de mars 2024
le décret a été signé par le colonel
assimi goïta l'homme fort de bamako deux
jours seulement après une nouvelle
réunion de la cedeao elle qui avait déjà
imposé le 9 janvier dernier de sévères
mesures de rétorsions commerciales et
financières comme la fermeture de
l'espace aérien malirat ses voisins ou
encore la suspension des échanges de
biens non essentiels
cette communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest voulait un délai
maximum de 16 mois les militaires
maliens ont finalement opté pour cinq
mois de plus bien loin de leur rêve
initiaux de conserver le pouvoir pendant
cinq ans un nouveau sommet de la cedeao
doit se tenir le 3 juillet prochain il
pourrait permettre une levée graduelle
des sanctions
si les différentes étapes de la
transition sont franchies avec succès
hier ne recevions el malick ndiaye
secrétaire national du pcf parti de
l'opposant sénégalais ousmane sont qu il
était venu nous parler de l'invalidation
de la liste de la coalition d'opposition
et oui askanwi pour les législatives de
juillet prochain il accuse les autorités
sénégalaises de vouloir écarter toute
opposition ce soir nous donnons la
parole et la possibilité aux autorités
sénégalaises de répondre à ces
accusations nous sommes en direct avec
le ministre des pêches et de l'économie
maritime cieux alioune d'oeil également
tête de liste de bonnes obock yaakaar
dans le département de dakar merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
ma première question est simple qu'avez
vous à répondre à el malick ndiaye qui
accuse le président macky sall de
vouloir écarter toute opposition
notamment pour ces élections
législatives
merci d'avoir à vous de nous avoir
handicapé vous exprimer seul ou à
l'antenne effectivement nous avons une
opposition qui lorsque le système
sénégalais et al'avantage il ne trouve
rien à redire mais dès que
ce système les mets devant leurs
responsabilités qui est un système
démocratique issue de différents
dialogue et de consensus entre les
parties il met tout de suite le chef de
l'état dans ce jeu alors qu'il n'a rien
à y voir à ce moment là je rappelle que
nous sortions d'élections locales
territoriales et que près de 79% des
collectivités locales au sénégal ont été
gagnés par le nouveau kaka parce que sur
les communes 438 communes sur les 553
existant au sénégal ont été gagnés par
le nouveau kaka et les tongs six
départements sur les 46 gagnés par le
benno wauquiez à cannes par contre quand
l'opposition gagné certaines villes
symboliques telles que ta carrière
vous avez bien vu le
compacteur de l'opposition crié victoire
alors qu'il s'agit du même système
électoral qui est en place qui n'est
jamais modifié avant 6 voire des
élections sauf consensus donc tout ce
qui est fait aujourd'hui est fait sur la
base du consensus
on ne peut se prévaloir de ses propres
turpitudes ils n'ont pas respecté des
règles mineures quelques celle qui
touche à la parité et mais également
c'est parfois celle qui toujours par
image et aujourd'hui on n'aimerait pas
que le droit soit dit ce droit est dit
aussi bien pour eux que pour nous parce
que vous savez très bien que nous
également nous avons des listes
invalidées
alors que nos listes valentino liste des
suppléants invalidé et et paritaire
parce qu'il y avait le même nombre
d'hommes que de femmes dans cette liste
mais il y avait juste un prince
d'agencement mais cela n'en pas n'a pas
empêché donc la cour d'invalider notre
liste donc voilà aujourd'hui une
opposition qui n'a pas de projet pour
les sénégalais parce que tout notre
projet est basé sur aujourd'hui la
recherche de l'instabilité au sénégal
ils ont en projet et qu'ils proposent
aux sénégalais pour dire nous voulons
lui par le voir pour juste deux ans
parce que on les entend lui dire qu'au
bout de deux ans il vole dissous de ce
parlement juste pour s'organiser d
immunité face à des personnes notamment
deux à trois personnes parmi ces leaders
qui aujourd'hui ont maille à partir avec
la justice n égalise alors d'enregistrer
juste pour en revenir à la validité de
la liste eh oui askan wi hier sur ce
plateau malick ndiaye le reconnaissait
que sa coalition avait commis une erreur
mais selon lui la loi lui permet de
rectifier ses erreurs et de pouvoir
conquérir mais sa coalition n'a pas eu
cette possibilité c'est aussi ce qu'il
dénonçait hier sur sur ce plateau
non la vérité des faits madame c'est
qu'effectivement ils ont investi une
personnes inéligibles
selon les dispositions de la loi
sénégalaise actuellement et il a été
permis de remplacer cette personne sauf
folie de la remplacer ils ont mis une
personne qui était déjà dans le risque
de super qu'ils ont eu à remplacer pas
cette personne là donc vous comprenez
qu'une personne peut être présente dans
deux ris c'est que la loi également
interdite donc voilà ce qui est là les
dispositions l'europe m et de procéder à
ces changements mais malheureusement
dans leur bataille interne de
positionnement parce que c'est ce qui a
caractérisé cette coalition qui ne
passer qu'à leur propre carrière et à
leurs besoins et non sénégalais ils sont
ils en sont allés à faire ce genre de
dérive monumentale qui font que cette
liste ce jeudi un complexe parce que la
même personne ne peut être présente sur
la liste des titulaires est présente sur
la liste des suppléants voilà le fond de
leurs difficultés aujourd'hui par
rapport à cette crise là si je prends
l'exemple département de dakar la cour
constitutionnelle a donné un avis en
train de s'y rendre une décision qui
n'est pas l'inventeur nous de la
coalition présidentielle parce que
rappelez vous que ces listes n'étaient
pas paritaire parce que sur la liste de
sept candidats les cinq étaient des
hommes et les deux étaient des femmes
alors de craignez-vous pas été tenues
pardonnez moi ne craignez vous pas tout
de même que le fait qu'une qu'une
importante coalition de l'opposition
soient exclues quelle qu'en soit la
raison
cela ne crée des tensions avant ce
scrutin du mois de juillet
mais madame vous avez la loi est la loi
aujourd'hui elle s'applique à nous nous
avons des listes qui ne vont pas
compétir notre liste des suppléants et
invalidé la liste
du moins et ont validé leur liste se
plaint toujours en lice donc nous
pouvons aller vraiment la vérité des
urnes déjà la veille ces salles au fond
du troll mais on ne peut pas dire que
quand à des dispositions de la loi qui
s'impose à nous pousse ne m'avantage pas
je lui oppose je dirais l'instabilité
l'appel à la violence l'appel à la
manifestation à la casse cela n'est pas
acceptable dans un état de droit et
c'est ça le fond du problème
actuellement avec l'opposition comme
jean c'est un problème de respect je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de la lys de
dakar ils ont commis leur book et ils
ont eu quand même on pousse et
l'indignité à venir vouloir créer des
troubles au niveau de l'interaction gel
des impôts tout en sachant qu'il était
la leur qu'ils ont fini par reconnaître
on leur a permis de faire les
modifications alors que la loi dit qu'il
fallait respecter lors des investitures
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui avoir bout de
la loi même cette liste aujourd'hui que
la cour a validé elle ne devait pas être
relevé mais un républicain nous nous
plions aux décisions de la cour conseil
alors il ya un appel à manifester demain
ce que vous êtes entier
inquiet pas du tout nous sommes vous
avez nous sommes un état de droit force
reste à la loi et si l'autorisation de
manifester elle sera encadrée ils le
feront je ne sais pas où j'ai passé les
autoriser ou parce qu'elle n'est pas
autorisée mais il faut se restera la loi
et l'état appliquera ses prérogatives
mais je pense que ce n'est pas la façon
que nous avons développé notre
démocratie notre système démocratique et
c'est monsieur qui se disent antisystème
au fond ils sont contre notre système
démocratique
ils sont contre notre système lyrique et
qui basé sur des valeurs culturelles
culturel un autre m'a de respect de
l'autre et de créer des croyances des
autres voilà déjà aujourd'hui qui
pensent que par la violence et par
l'appel en tout cas alain sélection on
peut imposer au fur et à mesure ses
volontés dans ces pays et cela n'est pas
rentable
merci beaucoup en tout cas à lyon dont
ministre des pêches et de l'économie
maritime je rappelle que vous êtes aussi
tête de liste de bonobos qui a car dans
le département de dakar merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
adama bictogo revient sur la scène
politique par la grande porte en côte
d'ivoire ce proche d'alassane ouattara
ténors de la politique ivoirienne a été
élu à la tête de l'assemblée nationale
avec plus de 97 % des voix sa
candidature a fait l'unanimité y compris
au sein de l'opposition
la correspondance à abidjan de samuel
bernard il a été plébiscité adama
bictogo est désormais à la tête de
l'assemblée nationale élue avec plus de
97 % des voix en fait toute l'opposition
s'est alignée autour de cette
candidature et c'est peut-être ce qu'il
faut retenir de cette élection une
opposition ranger derrière le candidat
du parti au pouvoir
une unanimité qui a d'ailleurs dénoncé
l'autre candidat jean michel amans coûts
qui s'est exprimée en lançant à ses
collègues de l'opposition les ivoiriens
nous regardent vous avez votre
conscience avec vous alors ce que l'on
peut retenir également c'est le retour
d'anama bictogo dans l'arène politique
en effet il faut rappeler qu'en en
février dernier alors qu'il était
directeur de l'exécutif du rhdp il est
nommé secrétaire exécutif placé sous
l'autorité d'un directoire dont il ne
fait pas partie alors le voir
aujourd'hui nommé pour siéger à la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale
c'est un retournement certains
pourraient croire que ce retour le
placerait en bonne position dans la
short list et futur successeur du
président alassane ouattara mais
beaucoup d'analystes l'exclu adama
bictogo est certes de retour mais pour
le moment il ne fait pas partie des élus
pour le poste suprême
direction l'île maurice où se tient le
grand rendez vous parce que vie des
athlètes africains les 22e championnat
d'afrique d'athlétisme a renvoyé deux
fois à cause de la pandémie démarre ce
mercredi 500 athlètes venant de 41 pays
seront en compétition pendant cinq jours
reportage de notre correspondant
abdallah et rallye
des installations nouvelles dont le
village de code dehors pour accueillir
une première compétition d'envergure les
22e championnat d'afrique d'athlétisme
auront lieu sur une piste flambant neuf
le directeur de la compétition un ancien
champion d'afrique au saut en hauteur
promet une reprise de compétition
mémorable aux visiteurs je crois que
dans l'africa n'a pas d'autres stades
comme celui là l'enjeu c'est que quand
les athètes sorte de ces championnats
d'afrique v10 whaou on n'a jamais eu un
championnat d'afrique de cette envergure
avec cette qualité d'officiel et puis
ces installations pour cela l'état
mauricien apporté sa pleine
participation logistique avec des
facilités ultra moderne il participe
aussi aux frais organisationnel qui
devrait coûter près d'un million d'euros
deux tiers de cette enveloppe sont
financés par le gouvernement et le reste
par des entreprises mauriciennes
l'organisation est rodée depuis des mois
avec la participation d'athlètes locaux
encadrés par 200 officiers et
volontaires plus de 500 athlètes du
continent seront de la partie certaines
vedettes sont arrivés plus tôt pour
s'acclimater comme la tunisienne dora
maar fodé venu défendre son titre même
si le moment n'est pas propice pour elle
le timing des championnats je considère
un peu tôt on a l'habitude d'avoir des
championnats un peu plus décalé jeu de
juillet ou août donc la préparation
n'est pas finalisé mais bien sûr on va
tout faire pour défendre le titre déjà
et faire une belle prestation des
prestations attendues également dans les
épreuves de sprint les organisateurs
annoncent 10 séries pour le 100 m hommes
ce technicien ivoirien qui a encadré de
nombreux talents africains prévoit de
belles dispute nous aurons un
championnat très élevé je prends ta g
l'exemple du 100 mètres dames avec le
kenya avec le si c'est avec sud
africaine ce sera une finale de 100 m
eur élevé par des femmes le grand absent
sera le public les autorités sanitaires
ont insisté pour un rendez-vous à huis
clos pour compenser les organisateurs
annoncent une retransmission en direct
de toutes les épreuves
c'est la fin du journal de l'afrique
l'info continue sur france 24
[Musique]